[Música]
economía en directo américa de francés
24 nuevamente con nosotros en esta mesa
de trabajo anhela blandón daniela
bienvenida otra vez gracias raúl vamos a
hablar de lo que se temía no pero puede
ser por una digamos o una decisión que
dice que es por mantenimiento del que
estamos hablando la suspensión por parte
de rusia del gas por el gasoducto nord
stream suspendida por mantenimiento si
raúl pues al alemania e italia son los
primeros damnificados por este cierre
temporal del mayor gasoducto de rusia o
que de rusia mejor lleva gas hasta
europa este mantenimiento que es anual
durará esta vez 10 días pero los
clientes europeos del gas ruso temen que
pueda prolongarse más por decisión
unilateral del kremlin moscú asegura que
hoy en día este gasoducto opera un 40
por ciento de su capacidad porque canadá
no le ha entregado unas turbinas que
están en reparación por las sanciones
que le ha impuesto occidente canadá dijo
que le va a devolver una turbina
reparada pero qué va a aumentar sus
sanciones contra rusia que niega que
esté usando este gas como arma de
presión política como dicen en europa
italia aseguró entonces que desde este
lunes disminuyó en un tercio el
suministro que le venía haciendo rusia
bueno y que media fue para entonces este
país para hacer frente a esta digamos
escasez o lo que podría pasar y medidas
que también podrían utilizar otros
países de la región los medios locales
en italia por ejemplo ya hablan de que
podría haber un racionamiento de las
empresas energéticas también limitar el
consumo para calefacción en los hogares
y para el alumbrado público vamos a
hablar también danny de uno de nuestros
temas del día lo compensamos en revista
de prensa con los haberes más débil por
supuesto lo vamos a tocar aquí en
finanzas a darle un repaso entonces las
finanzas de la empresa uber envuelta en
la polémica de la filtración de
documentos que salpica macrón entonces
recordemos primero rápidamente de qué se
trata es un reportaje de guardián
compartido con el consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación que revela que la
aplicación de transporte uber cortejo a
políticos de alto nivel y violó las
leyes para que su empresa entraran
ciudades todo el mundo todo esto
supuestamente son más de 124.000
documentos que abarcan 5 años entre 2013
y 2017 que incluyen correos electrónicos
mensajes de texto que muestran por
ejemplo que el presidente francesa
emmanuelle mccrone entonces ministro de
economía ayudó al lobby de la firma en
francia también involucran a la ex jefe
digital de la unión europea neelie kroes
aquí en el bloque comunica comunitario
ya le pidió más información ahora
entrando en materia este es un escándalo
que no es de poca monta raúl si se
observa que uber es una multinacional
que presta su servicio en más de 10.000
ciudades del mundo con 1.700 millones de
viajes registrados sólo en el primer
trimestre de este año esto nos da que si
sacamos la calculadora unos 19 millones
de viajes en promedio por día en los
tres primeros meses de este año la
empresa duplicó sus ingresos a casi
siete mil millones de dólares pero
registró pérdidas por 5 mil 900 millones
de dólares bueno y seguimos por supuesto
a nuestro repaso económico daniela y no
podemos dar un lado un país que
actualmente está sumido una crisis grave
económica y política estamos hablando
desde la ncaa vamos a repasar los datos
macroeconómicos bueno desde finales de
junio el gobierno ya había alertado que
la economía cargada de deudas de la
nación insular había colapsado pues se
había quedado sin dinero para pagar los
alimentos también el combustible ahora
entonces repasamos estas cifras del
gobierno debe 51 mil millones de dólares
de los que no puede pagar ni los
intereses ni mucho menos el capital y su
moneda se ha derrumbado en un 80 por
ciento en poco más de dos años
encareciendo las importaciones y
empeorando la inflación que ya está
fuera de control un 40 por ciento anual
57 por ciento si se trata solamente de
alimentos según datos oficiales este es
un país de raúl de 22 millones
habitantes en el que 3 millones reciben
ayuda de emergencia según la onu que
también dice que 9 de cada 10 familias
se saltan alguna de las comidas al día y
hacen enormes filas también para
conseguir algo de combustible ahora
estamos hablando de lo que pasa
actualmente pero como sé hasta este
punto tan grave pues mire se va creo que
puedo simplemente se va a sorprender con
esta respuesta porque si blanca era una
economía que crecía rápidamente con una
clase media bastante boyante pero todo
comenzó a cambiar en 2019 cuando la a la
corrupción histórica estructural de este
país se sumó una serie de atentados que
ustedes recordarán en semana santa que
mataron a dos ríos 60 personas pues lo
que hizo este atentado fue devastar el
turismo que es una fuente clave de
divisas después vino la pandemia por
supuesto para terminar de hundir la
economía y con todo esto el país está
precipitando hacia la bancarrota no
tiene dinero para importar gasolina
leche gas o cocinar el gas para cocinar
tampoco para papel higiénico y tiene una
enorme deuda que a propósito ya no está
pagando claro daniela complicada la
situación es el anca cifra el día pues a
de raúl a hasta un 8 por ciento ha caído
la acción de twitter en operaciones
previas al mercado este lunes borrando
de un plumazo más de 2.000 millones de
dólares en capitalización bursátil de la
empresa en la bolsa de nuevo y todo esto
después de que el viernes el
multimillonario y los que es el dueño de
tesla se arrepintiera de su acuerdo para
comprar a la compañía y allanar el
camino para una larga batalla legal y
sinceramente daniela yo nunca creí que
los hubiera
[Música]
44 millones de dólares que él realmente
no tenía en efectivo y algo adicional
raúl es que han pasado muchas cosas
desde que él hizo el anuncio nos estamos
encaminando a una recesión y eso no le
conviene a nadie comprar ahora danny
muchísimas gracias más adelante les
vamos directo hasta londres